instagram came out of one wanting to be
my own boss i was like you know what i
want to work for myself i want to work
on ideas i really hope i'm going to make
money this is kevin systrom in 2010 he
launched instagram three years later he
sold it to facebook for one billion
dollars
but instagram nearly didn't happen his
first app was a complete disaster and
only had about a hundred active users
after its launch until one day during a
conversation with his wife he had an
epiphany that changed the course of his
life he went on to build one of the most
popular social media apps and became a
billionaire
this is the story of how a single reply
sparked the idea for a hundred billion
dollar company
kevin was born on december 30th 1983. he
grew up in holliston massachusetts a
wealthy suburb of boston during high
school kevin was introduced to computer
programming his interest grew from
playing doom 2 and he even created his
own levels as a teenager kevin was
obsessed with record collecting and
djing while still in high school he used
to have his friends sneak him into
nightclubs in the boston area open for
established djs
kevin applied to stanford university he
had planned to study computer science
but once he arrived he decided to switch
majors to management science and
engineering
kevin soon became interested in
photography during his junior year he
spent a semester in florence a city in
central italy to study photography it
was in florence that kevin stumbled upon
the aesthetic that would define
instagram in the early days one of his
professors showed him a cheap film
camera called a holger which takes hip
vintage looking photos
right before his senior year at stanford
kevin interned at a podcasting company
called odio odio was founded by evan
williams who went on to create twitter
twitter ceo jack dorsey was also working
at odeo at the time and he and kevin
became good friends in 2004 while kevin
was still in college he met facebook ceo
mark zuckerberg he tried to recruit him
to work for facebook but kevin thought
facebook was just a fad and turned him
down after graduation kevin was offered
a job at google after three years at
google kevin left to work at a social
travel recommendation startup called
nextstop
around the same time kevin began working
on his own app which he initially named
bourbon after his favorite spirit the
app combined location-based social
networking and photo sharing he made the
prototype of the app and pitched it to
baseline ventures and andreessen
horowitz during a party after the first
meeting he decided to quit his job in
order to work on bourbon full-time
within two weeks of quitting his job he
received a five hundred thousand dollar
seed funding round from both baseline
ventures and andreessen horowitz soon
after kevin brought on mike krieger as a
co-founder mike also graduated from
stanford just two years behind kevin
soon after mike joined the pair decided
to focus on bourbon
on its launch the app completely tanked
bourbon only had around a hundred active
users most users who tried the app said
it was far too complicated and did too
much kevin and mike's first venture
together was a complete disaster
instead of trying to fix the issues of
bourbon they pivoted kevin and mike
decided to ditch bourbon and instead
focused on building a photo sharing app
back then photo sharing apps were
already quite common but there wasn't an
app that allowed users to post great
looking photos for their followers kevin
and mike were working on their app until
one day while kevin was walking along
the beach with his wife he asked his
wife whether she was interested in his
photo sharing app but his wife said that
she wasn't interested kevin said that
his friends used filters on their photos
so she just replied well you should
probably have filters then
her reply went on to change his life
on that same day kevin went home to his
computer and started to make the first
ever instagram filter called x pro 2 it
is still used in the app today
in october 2010 kevin and mike
officially changed the name to instagram
the name was a combination of instant
and telegram
when the app went live more than 25 000
people downloaded it in the first 24
hours crashing instagram servers even
celebrities like kim kardashian justin
bieber and beyonce started using the app
in 2012 facebook had been in months of
turmoil and scandals mark zuckerberg
even saw instagram as a threat to
facebook so in april 2012 mark
zuckerberg and facebook acquired
instagram for one billion dollars going
into the deal kevin owned 40 of
instagram so he made an estimated 400
million dollars from the sale after
facebook's acquisition of instagram the
app was continuously being developed and
improved upon
instagram added more and more features
for its users the app continued its
success as it gained more users year
after year it also started to become one
of facebook's biggest revenue drivers as
its popularity increased however in 2017
instagram was accused on multiple
occasions of copying various new
functions from its closest competitor
snapchat regarding the issue kevin
argued that all new apps launched by
tech companies nowadays are remixes of
existing apps and all ideas are original
when you remix them and bring your own
flavor despite instagram's success
however there were reportedly growing
tensions with mark zuckerberg over the
direction of the app
instagram's autonomy began to crumble
then in september 2018 kevin and mike
abruptly announced that they were
stepping down as ceo and cto
respectively after leaving instagram
kevin and mike kept a low profile though
they did attend a few conferences in
2019
kevin has been quiet on instagram too he
has since deleted all the photos he
posted on the app over the past couple
of years
today instagram is still one of the most
popular social media apps in the world
with over 1 billion active monthly users
instagram is one of facebook's most
valuable assets in 2020 instagram
generated an estimated 24 billion
dollars in revenue nowadays instagram
has a valuation of a hundred billion
dollars
[Music]
these days kevin is worth an estimated
1.7 billion dollars he's recently been
involved in the fashion industry and has
met and worked with several well-known
designers he's also attended the mech
gala multiple times kevin took a failed
app and turned it into one of the most
popular social media apps in the world
he managed to build a company and sell
it for one billion dollars in just three
short years
there's a lesson in every story what can
we learn from kevin's journey to success
instead of persevering with bourbon
kevin decided to pivot
that became the single most important
decision he ever made with his company a
pivot is fundamentally changing the
direction of a business when you realize
the current products or services aren't
meeting the needs of the market
kevin recognized that the market didn't
want all the complicated features such
as bookings and point systems
but instead wanted a simple app that
allowed users to share good looking
photos with their followers
so he pivoted
a big part of entrepreneurship is the
ability to solve problems kevin
identified a problem in the market at
the time there wasn't an app that
allowed people to add filters to photos
to share with their followers so he
created an app that solved the problem
and was massively rewarded
ultimately making him incredibly rich
and successful what do you guys think
was he a brilliant developer who
revolutionized the industry or did he
just rip off other apps the comment
section in this one will be very
interesting thanks for staying till the
end of this video if you enjoyed this
video then be sure to hit the like
button drop a comment subscribe and hit
the notification bell for more content
like this also be sure to check out our
other videos on this channel links are
in the description and we'll see you in
the next one